après une longue période de pluie
clément mercier peut enfin sortir son
pulvérisateur pour protéger ses champs
de betteraves sucrières ce céréalier de
27 ans installé depuis trois ans
seulement vient de subir deux coups durs
la jaunisse de la betterave qui a
anéanti la récolte de 2020 et la vague
de gel du printemps qui l'a contraint à
ressemer toutes ces parcelles de quoi se
poser des questions sur son avenir
d'exploitants agricoles entre les est
différent enfin les évolutions
réglementaires le climat qui change et
ça on en est bien conscient et on peut
pas non plus agir qu'à notre échelle
pour pour le faire évoluer et se sont
faits plutôt s'adapter à travailler avec
donc oui on se pose des questions sur le
côté notamment économique puisque ça
reste tf1 ont fait ça si pour en vivre
vivre de leur production c'est ce que
veulent tous les paysans mais ceux qui
adhèrent au syndicat des jeunes
agriculteurs sont en tout début de
carrière et font face à de redoutables
défis techniques juridiques ou
budgétaire il espère surtout que la
prochaine réforme de la politique
agricole commune n'ajoutera pas une
instabilité supplémentaires savoir une
vraie visibilité se peut une visibilité
à trois ou cinq ans il est trop tard se
tendent constat qu'on se mette dans le
bain on est déjà rendu à cinq ans si à
chaque fois pour repartir d'une page
blanche pour évoluer on ne peut pas
avoir une visibilité sur du long terme
avec des grandes stratégies et une
visibilité économique faut pas faire de
l'environnement sont sexy a pas
d'économie qui a pas d'environnement si
l économique et de l'environnement tout
le monde s'y retrouve et le monde à
l'école peut avancer correctement
les jeunes agriculteurs sont plutôt
europhile une communauté agricole
européenne soudé leur semble être le
meilleur rempart contre les concurrences
de la russie de l'amérique eau de l'asie
ils attendent de cette future pac des
protections à long terme pour réussir le
grand renouvellement des générations
aujourd'hui 55 % des agriculteurs
français ont plus de 50 ans